good morning Hank it's Tuesday and today
I am going to apply for health insurance
Twice first using the exchanges created
by the Affordable Care Act and second
using the private insurance options that
existed before the Affordable Care Act
which by the way still exists alright
let's get right to it
okay so first we're gonna go through the
new health care exchanges it is
currently 1:11 p.m. I am going to Google
I need to sign up for Obamacare BAM took
me right there okay my first name is
John create account done tada saying
please wait still saying please wait
just gonna go to tumblr for a while
signup unsuccessful dang it alright I'm
gonna try again first name is John my
last name is green I live in Indiana I
do have an email address thank you for
asking
alright I'm back to please wait screen
big money no whammies signup
unsuccessful well this is not going well
at all I'm gonna keep trying because
that is my commitment my name is John my
last name is green I live in Indiana I
do have an email address
now 1:16 p.m. five minutes into my
applying for Obamacare experience so if
I'm gonna say a little underwhelming do
I know my first name I mean at this
point I if I almost have it memorized
okay my account cannot be created this
time because the system is unavailable I
don't want to I'm a little bit they
don't get frustrated
I'll call free some room service no no I
don't like I don't like mayonnaise no
ma'am
yeah um yeah do you have like Diet Pepsi
perfect
hahahahaha having it count I got to go
to my email address to sign up for it
though now it says get insurance John
what would you like to do apply for new
coverage yes okay my date of birth yes I
know that oh and then I to tell you
about the next person that's my wife the
third person is my kid his name is Henry
is very cute person 404 that would be my
new baby suddenly it's pretty easy it's
all questions I know how to answer
alright now I'm going to sign it submit
no one applying for health coverage on
this application is currently
incarcerated agree unless Henry has done
something in the last couple of minutes
okay and quick update
now 2:00 p.m. so I am 49 minutes into my
Affordable Care Act application I have
now uploaded a photograph of my driver's
license so they can verify my identity
so then I can go in and decide which
kind of insurance I want I will now
attempt to get to that same place with
the private insurance that existed
before the Affordable Care Act I have
that application right here let's get
started my name huh it's just just so
happens I know that I am married here is
my social security number okay I just
got to the really scary part of this
application where it says incorrect or
incomplete information on this
application may result in voidance of
coverage or claim denial so I need to be
um really I guess honest about all the
questions has the applicant while
operating a motor vehicle been involved
in an accident or received a moving
violation if yes provide details in
medical history details because of
course that time I rolled through a stop
sign is part of my medical history old
through stop sign got a ticket felt
shame is any family member pregnant or
an expected mother or father I hope not
in the last five years as any applicant
been diagnosed as having elevated
cholesterol diabetes or sugar in the
blood stroke mental emotional or
behavioral disorder oh I was on a good
role to be got to mental emotional or
behavioral disorder in the last five
years has any applicant had any
indication signs or symptoms of any
disease disorder injury or adverse
finding I mean yes is any applicant
currently or in the last five years used
alcoholic beverages in excess of 14
drinks per week yes during the week of
the Indianapolis 500
yes definitely this application is like
fully 25 pages long and the language of
it makes my head hurt oh this is taking
forever
I have to Hank every three seconds I
have to look
the phone number of a different doctor
the sucks in the last ten years has any
applicant been hospital confined yes
orbital cellulitis plus my wife was
hospital confined when she had the
babies had surgery yes my gallbladder
out or discussed surgery I mentioned it
in conversation so basically you have to
write down every time you or someone in
your family has been to the doctor in
the last ten years every time you got a
medical test and if the results were not
normal what the results were so that's
what I've been doing for the last two
hours okay it is now 4:13 p.m. I think
that I have finished my medical history
details and there's all this really
complicated stuff I don't understand
about information practices but anyway
I'm not going to read it I'm just gonna
consider it finished at 2 hours and 16
minutes
so to summarize Hank in neither case did
I actually get insurance however even
with all the server errors it was more
than twice as fast to apply under the
Affordable Care Act private exchanges
that it was to apply in the old way and
it's also much less confusing and
intrusive like in the old way I had to
list every single time I went to the
doctor in a new way they didn't ask me
anything except whether I smoked it's
not really fair to compare the
experience of buying health insurance on
these new exchanges to the experience of
buying a surprisingly affordable poster
at dftba.com the only real analog is
what it was like to buy insurance before
and as far as I can tell it has gotten
dramatically better even though the
government could stand to buy some new
servers so I think I hope you enjoyed my
afternoon spent in the world of health
insurance I know I didn't I'll see you
on Friday actually might eat before
Friday because I might do like a special
bonus video I don't know
and this little government shutdown it's
got everything off first corroborating
prop here at blonde Brothers